Anthony Correa from Krypton is
suggesting that the new art 628 II will
perform better than Titan B but coming
at a cheaper price in the gtx 980ti at
$650
[Music]
welcome to hari sabe
we can't really determine whether or not
Anthony is correct however what is
certain is that the architects 2080 will
definitely go out of the stock right
after its release we've seen this is
past GPUs and is it quite common in the
tech world for example just last year
the 87 RK what Adams talked quite soon
after its release NVIDIA is probably
taking into account all their past
experiences in order to make this stock
situation not that bad
however there's a lot of external
factors it's time that weren't present
in other GPU launches GP practice had
been inflated since January and they
really only have been getting better for
the last two months and so there is
still a huge population who have yet to
buy GPU and they were waiting for eleven
serious launch Norse snag one as soon as
they can also this is one of the most
highly anticipated series from Nvidia of
all time we have really never seen this
many rumours leaks and speculation
surrounding GP release till now as a
result there is a lot of excessive hype
over the normal hype surrounding a GPU
release and as a result there's a high
chance of these GPUs going out of stock
soon after the release and the same
story will most likely apply with
altered or apparent cards as well so
whichever cars are playing to buy it
make sure to buy it quickly in order to
avoid being left out if you're worried
about the performance and you're not
quite sure if it's worth that type of
money well here's the thing it may not
be up to a level to tighten B but it
will definitely be better than the gtx
980ti
it will have GTD rs6 memory rate racing
technology and being the new tutoring
architecture also there is simply no way
that nvidia is going to launch a new
flagship product that is worse than a
current flagship so if anything it will
at least be slightly faster than gtx
980ti
as for price it may just be six hundred
and fifty dollars i thought that i may
cost $7 just like the gtx 280 did at
launch or maybe 750
great race technology and GDR six memory
however after Sumer I'm actually leaning
more towards the 650 to 700 dollar mark
so if you pre-order as soon as you can
here's essentially what you were getting
a car that is better than gtx 980ti for
the exact same price you have to
remember that many people have been
waiting many many months for this series
to finally come out and they have had
their eye on a certain GPU and they're
going to buy it as soon as I finally can
because to a lot of these people money
was really never an issue it was simply
the principle of overpaying for an
almost outdated card and now that these
GPS are coming out for MSRP they will
buy it really quickly overall I think
that it is clear there's a lot of
anticipation for the new 1100 series due
to situation of the GPU market over the
last couple of months as a result
there's going to be a lot of stress
being put on the new 2000 series supply
and unfortunately in video probably
won't be able to meet that demand I
usually tell you guys to wait and make
well thought-out decisions but this is
definitely not the time to wait this is
a time to just choose a card and just go
for it unless you want to wait even
longer but that's just what I think what
do you guys think do you guys think in
video we'll be able to handle all this
demand make sure comment down below what
you guys think because I do read all my
comments I'm curious as to what you guys
think to make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hardy I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]